foreign
it is an honor to have you here today
welcome back to the GSB thank you I'm
very very excited to be back every time
so
now I'd like to start off by thanking
you for not only helping to keep the
world connected during the pandemic but
for creating a product that brought all
of us a lot of joy and laughs too
everything from Zoom weddings to zoom
attire I'm thinking professional tops in
pajama bottoms and everything in between
so thank you that's why I like Stanford
like GSP because I know Stanford GSP
never use any other product
that is a true statement now few
Founders can say that their companies
have turned into a global verb take us
back to the very beginning how did you
first come up with the idea for zoom
back to 20 2010 time frame you know I
was at Cisco I was cooperative vice
president over there and when I came to
America in 1997 I joined WebEx as one
for the first little several funding
Engineers I worked extremely hard you
know try to make a WebEx better and
fortunately and after the 10 or 11 years
hard work back to 2010 time frame every
time I can tell you why talking to the
customer
I did not see a single heavy customer
every morning I woke up I did not want
to go to office because when you talk to
the customer care customer every time
share their pain point the mission of
the video quality is not a very good
mobile experience horrible I really
wanted to fix that problem unfortunately
and you know they told me that that's
not a good idea you still can sell a lot
of airbags why do you want to
cannibalize WebEx and it took me one
year I failed to convince others
I guess I should have come to GSP
learning how to convince others so I
guess I did not you know take that
course I failed to convince others so
but anyway so finally I decided to leave
to build my own solution and a key part
in your story you mentioned coming to
the United States in the late 1990s that
path to get to the U.S wasn't
necessarily smooth was it what kind of
challenges did you run into coming to
Silicon Valley uh gee actually that's a
long time ago I thought it was pretty
straightforward I was a very good
engineer I should get a visa and
fortunately
and had took me
a nance attempts like to get here my
Visa application got rejected 80 times
and but luckily I go to the the final
that we saw and came here but looking
back I really appreciate it because the
reason why his mother got to practice my
perseverance right so and again took me
one and a half years to come to America
to pursue my American dream so
and keeping on the international Fame I
don't know if you know but we have quite
a few of our classmates in the audience
who are Internationals and are living in
the U.S for the first time what were
some of those first years like in the
U.S as someone who had never lived in
Silicon Valley or the United States
before
that's a good question I was I would
received back to 1997 and I remember
before I came here I was extremely
excited right because when I have a kid
you know always uh read the stories of
HP and the Silicon Valley Apple very
excited however after you landed he
didn't realize it's not that easy
because you have learned the culture
history how to you know uh you know make
new friends and build a trust language
barrier all kinds of things and luckily
I live in Silicon Valley you know
Silicon Valley not only the worldwide
Innovation Center but also here the
people here is extremely friendly a lot
of leaders you know they would like to
help you I think after several months I
feel like already part of the sitting
Valley and looking back I was wow this
is the best experience yeah and I love
your optimism you came from you know
China to the United States not speaking
English applied for a Visa nine times
rose up in WebEx and Cisco and then you
came to the Stanford Graduate School of
Business what role did being at the GSB
play and that Vision to turn an idea you
had back in 1987 into a company that is
now that's a security questions anytime
if I have a time I take a break I want
to be you know part of GSB you know
group I wanted to see to hear like you
guys I think very excited the reason why
I said so is you know back to you know
early early time I came here you know
before I came here I was very confident
I said wow you know America huge
opportunity right as long as you work
hard you can achieve your dream and
however I offered you know I work for
WebEx for a while you know quite often I
work very very hard right and make a
very good progress however you know
sometimes your confidence level suddenly
not a very high was as high as the first
time first day when you landed here and
because it makes some progress you do
not want to take a risk you know you do
not want to start over right and back to
2006 and I I participated you know the
Stanford and the tsp SCP program
I can tell you actually just literally
after the summer the day after I left
the Stanford I felt like more like the
first day when I landed the San
Francisco Airport my confidence level
was extremely high I almost created a
job and to start a new company at that
time
and but anyway so you know being here
just one summer my confidence level is
at least twice High you know for all the
GSB students you're here 21 or two years
I guarantee you I guarantee you your
confidence level probably four times or
four times five if you are not I can
tell your background program SCP program
also pretty good too but anyway I was so
grateful to stand for GSB in a greater
curriculum right greater you know a lot
of kids stories and greater professors
you know and yeah I just by the way
after that every time you know to manage
the company manager team is pretty
challenging and sometimes you know you
feel like a very lonely a long time
every time I feel like that if I come
back to GSB and to stand up campus I can
tell you I sort of fully recharge myself
that's another reason why I'm here today
I need to fully recharge myself so
it's definitely a special place I agree
with you very special and also with in
order to mention entrepreneurial
atmosphere here in GSP I think a great
opportunity I think for all of you after
you graduate yeah
well fast forward that company that you
had the idea for way back when you were
inspired at the GSB that company has
fundamentally changed the way that we
all stay connected that's what DSP you
know taught us right to build something
to change the world absolutely but Zoom
is seen as something that was an
overnight success but that wasn't the
case was it
yeah it's two causes many marriages
effort I think prior to covet I probably
most of the you know people never heard
about Zoo right but we were very patient
you know as long as we keep improving
the product experience to make sure our
customers happy I know sooner or later
we are going to achieve something yeah
and so it sounds like a lot of hard work
went into it and part of that hard work
was finding investors for Zoom it's hard
to Fathom but back then investors
weren't jumping at the bit to invest in
Zoom what lessons do you have from that
period of time that you can share with
the entrepreneurs and the aspiring
entrepreneurs in the audience today it's
good a new VC here so I can share the
story so and after I left the Cisco I
thought I was a vice president of
engineering I built WebEx I have also a
lot of connections it should be
straightforward right target visits they
all want to invest you that's my that's
my thought
but I was completely wrong and I try to
talk almost every VC I knew nobody
wanted to invest me and plus some other
VC friend told me that Eric
as long as you build something else our
check was ready for you so meaning you
should not build another video
collaboration solution
and I remember that I talked when we see
and you know again you know the way
submission that's horrible idea you
should not do that but on the way back
and I told myself
you are wrong I got to prove you are
wrong so after that back to the office I
changed my you know the screensaver you
know to be you are wrong so and
I removed that after we became a nasda
public company so so menu actually when
you try to reach the capital right you
know for sure we are humble right
there's a reason why we see that you
know invest you right you got it to and
understand why it's good for you right
but sometimes and this is might be wrong
if you think you're right which is a
wrong it's not a balancing right give
you more reasons you've got to work
harder to prove they are wrong that's
what had happened to us yeah I think
that's an incredibly important lesson
that I know a lot of us starting
companies will will keep in mind don't
give up yeah yeah absolutely and often
we seem not be right so especially for
those visits you never got got educated
here utsb right so
and I think another important lesson in
that story is learning to Pivot as you
mentioned Zoom was a successful company
before the pandemic serving mainly B2B
clients and then boom the pandemic
happens and you have to add b2c into
that portfolio what were some of the big
lessons that came away and how did you
rapidly adjust to such a significant
expansion in your customer base yeah I
think that's a as a tough experience
because you know so right Zoom was built
to serve for Enterprise consumer prior
to pandemic crisis and during the Panama
crisis you know and we had so many you
know the new users consumers all kinds
of new use cases like K-12 schools or
Tyler Madison Teddy Hills you know we
never thought about those consumer use
cases and the mistake we made is you
know prior to you know Clover the crisis
we had a lot of secure features but
normally we work together with the
Enterprise ITT you know they are going
to test our product with some QC process
they are going to enable some secure
features or privacy features and however
for those you know first time consumers
experience very different they do not
have ITT right then we realize we made a
huge mistake not only did we put a lot
of offering the service but also we
should put a role of serving the IIT for
them and so I will learn a hard lesson
we quickly took actions and we we went
to trust back because you know when you
sort of lost your trust you got to make
sure take actions as quickly as possible
and also keep everything open and
transparent why you made a mistake
what's your you know what's your you
know the effort right how to you know
how to fix all those problems keep
everything open transparent communicate
with the customers you know that's a
lesson learned and finally finally we
want the trust back
absolutely and I want to pick up on a
word you said which is mistake something
that I admire so much about you is a
leader is your honesty and transparency
like you were talking about and for
example when you know data and security
issues were brought up during the
pandemic your response was to publicly
roll out a statement of how we're fixing
it here are the problems that we see and
this is how we're going to take feedback
into account you touch on this a little
bit but would love to dive in a bit more
how do you see transparency being
important in leadership and how can we
as Future Leaders and leaders in the
business World think about being
transparent in difficult situations I
think first of all during the difficult
institution you go to this group six
step take a step back right try to
understand what had happened right those
in the users you know why you know share
with you all those issues because I
think they care about us ultimately you
know for for us if we can address all
those problems who is going to benefit
the zoom right ourselves that's why we
embrace you know all those you know uh
challenges right and at the same time we
go to and take actions right you know
you know first of all I needed to tell
you know publicly tell them sorry I mess
up
you know we got to do fix you know for
all the issues we know what's the
problem what's your cause what's the
past and the solution to address all
those issues right and I personally
hosted it weekly in a security in a
meetings and with all the you know and
the users and also share with them
transparently about those effort plans
programs how we double down on security
and privacy a lot of things like you
know end users they're pretty smart they
understand you know are you going to try
hard to fix those issues or you just
need to talk about that right so that's
that's in the world we what if we did
you know you know two years ago at the
zoom and you know prior to you know
coveted crisis you know look at our
privacy security very small around a
dozen people and now we have more than
200 full-time employees right and
because of that and we we took privacy
and executed very very seriously because
a lot of secure companies they deploy
Zoom garment customers so you zoom and
finally the customers really like it
zoom and saying yeah you guys you know
admitted those mistakes and then quickly
fix that problem and also make it better
even better than any of our competitors
in terms of security and privacy
because you and a lot of people relying
on you can I get a show of hands how
many people use zoom during the pandemic
I think I know the answer but thank you
I use it too
yeah there we go John Dean Levin
mentioned this stat before but I want to
bring it out again because I think it's
incredible the number of Zoom users
increased from 10 million to 300 million
sorry that's amazing participant being
participants yes meeting participants
per day in just four months I mean Zoom
was really pushed into the spotlight and
also given a chance to shine walk us
through your thought process when did
you realize that Zoom could play a
critical role during the pandemic
I think of course I and
you know I remember I think the first
time in my daughter like her you know
school and they also included school
every online I remember it's a Monday
morning the first time you know my you
know I worked so hard you know and my my
daughter even though I don't know what I
was doing but you know and she asked me
the first time her dad how to raise my
hand during the zoom call I realized wow
you know I never thought about my kids
they are going to use zoom and I think
the first time I think I realized wow
this is a huge potential and I didn't
realize in you know and there's a huge
opportunity at that time how to and help
the world how to help the community in
the society right this is you know the
responsibility on our Shooters right the
good news we we heavily invested in our
company culture the team working worked
extremely hard I can tell you I
personally had a way more you know
syllabus nice than any time in my career
and along with a lot of Engineers
because we need a capacity India Brazil
a lot of other countries quite often
maybe maybe there's a small glitches
you've got to fix quickly I can tell you
wow that's a six months time frame and
the good news you know was over so it's
it's pretty tough very challenging yeah
I can't even imagine I have to ask
hearing about the responsibility hearing
about all the things you were thinking
about the sleepless nights how do you
stay grounded and how do you prioritize
what really matters
that's why I like a GSP you know I learn
a lot of stuff I was already mentally
prepared well right because on the one
hand if you really want Beauty something
to make the water better to change the
world for sure you are going to face all
kinds of challenges right mentally you
got to prepare well meaning may not be
today maybe next year maybe next week
right so mentally we were at least I was
prepared very well so when that happens
I realize on the one hand you are facing
the challenge on the other hand you re
you also I realize if you can overcome
all those challenges right guess what
you know your company your team yourself
will become a very different become much
better right that's why we lever that
opportunity look at every corners of our
business what we can do differently to
improve I think you know our you know
team size for example prior to code
we're going to have a little bit over 2
000 employees you know for now actually
we hired over six thousand voice over
the past 18 months right and to make
sure further skills are very that's a
great opportunity for us for the future
and to position us very well to
transform our business from being a
video conferencing killer app company to
be a platform business that's a huge
opportunity and the opportunities that
Zoom has even in the future are huge I
want to come to a question first though
that is something that we talk a lot
about here at the GSB which is work-life
balance I've heard that you are in
addition to running one of the biggest
companies also an active parent on your
children's basketball teams how do you
balance and how do you think about that
work-life balance between spending time
on your company while also spending time
with your family yeah that that's one
thing I guess during my time in GSB I
did not learn how to balance that
because you know and the reason why and
at that time I also thought of a balance
and I talked with many other classmates
and some professors try to try to you
know figure out a way how to balance
later on realized as long as you think
about balance there's no answer
you know think about if you like work
and you know it's uh it's part of life
you know you're passionate about
something and especially you are good at
something and you also can create a
value and if you like that you know
that's a part of a life you know work is
life life is work don't listen about
balance that's what two is what if
there's a conflict between work and life
you know at a zoom and our principle is
very simple whenever there's a conflict
being worked alive
your family first always like that you
know taking my personal experience for
example many years ago and I think
that's our Christmas party and my son's
in high school they also you know they
are going to have a basketball game and
in San Francisco I told our team sorry
that's a conflict I'm going to enjoy my
son's basketball game I'm going to I'll
be I I would be very late to the
Christmas party right that's our
philosophy doing something about balance
find your passion you know work is alive
life is a work at the same time if
there's a conflict family first that's
you know very simple but doing a single
balance every single balance every day
you are going to struggle every month is
you're gonna struggle yeah in addition
to putting Family First it sounds like
happiness is something that is so
important to you how do you take that
personal value of happiness and then
translate into a company culture that's
also based on happiness
yeah so company culture is extremely
important looking back I think that's uh
that's one thing I I personally you know
feel proud of because on the first of
the day when I started Zoom I remember
when we did the two things I usually
done company culture and value and it
was about to use the furniture right to
to for a table so but anyway so our
comedy culture just two words
very easy right very catchy deliver
happiness
and the meaning and for me as a CEO of a
company my number and priority is to
make sure Zoom employee happy I believe
if you have a hyper employees you're
going to have hybrid customers right so
I do all I can to think about how to
make make sure Zoom employee happy and
at the same time you know employee you
know they are going to make a customer
happy you know that's our company the
culture yeah wow and it sounds like as
CEO you have a lot of people to keep
happy your customers your employers you
know shareholders what happens when one
of these stakeholder groups isn't happy
how do you keep them on board so first
of all we sort of tell them why what's
the purpose of you know life right the
purpose of life is really about the
happiness right and also the sustainable
happiness comes from making others happy
right you know for those you know
shareholders right like a stock of
prices down you know they are not happy
we tell them hey this is more short-term
thing right and plus and we should you
know communicate you know learn
Community with them you know very well
about you know why you know let's say
you want to buy the Zuma stock why you
become a share you know the city holder
right and ultimately we want to make
sure you know those you know the
employees or shareholders and it truly
understand our company information right
in the canola when we look at the
short-term stuff right and if we do not
understand the purpose of life it's just
know focus on the short-term happenings
right for sure you know that's not an
hour you know our company the culture we
always think about what you can do
differently to focus on long-term
sustainable happiness right rather than
just a short-term happiness you know
like sometimes employee you just focus
on the money or the power and or the
title those are the short-term happiness
in the longer term right you got to look
at make sure make sure the the happiness
is sustainable always think about in the
long run make a customer happy making
employee happy and it's down the road
you know I think you will get a much
better return yeah and keeping on that
happiness thing because I think it's
it's so unique to who you are as a
person something else that we think a
lot about here at the GSB is what kind
of leader we want to become we have a
class where we ask ourselves why would
someone follow us given your background
being an immigrant to the U.S being an
engineer overcoming adversity putting
happiness at the center of everything
how would you describe your leadership
style and how has that evolved over the
years
I think of my leadership style for sure
again and I I was very fortunate to live
in Senegal Valley and I've you know
doing my career here I had so many
mentors you know truly helped me they
were shipped my leadership style and I
think many years ago I would say my
leadership style is more like a very
Hands-On leader right and I tried to
work so hard trying to understand you
know again this is kind of sure to come
to jsb First otherwise I'm not going to
spend so much time to learn like a you
know Marketing sales and support and the
strategy and you know and I learned a
lot and because I really understand how
business operates right and it's one of
very Hands-On leadership that's kind of
my you know uh personal style but later
on I realized that's not a skillable
right you know how to delegate you know
some of the very important Works to your
team how to make sure you are surrounded
by a lot of leaders probably they are
even better than you you know on some us
I think I learned a lot otherwise
especially over the past two years and I
do not think I can sleep right and given
so many challenges so many opportunities
right that's my leadership style I think
I think completely changed like how to
balance between the Hands-On leadership
and also the delegates
so it sounds like as Zoom scaled you had
to adapt your leadership style to fit
that so it could scale with that
otherwise there's no way to scale you
know up your business yeah exactly we
talked about Zoom pre-pandemic we talked
about Zoom during the pandemic let's
look to the Future and five years from
now what is zoom going to look like and
what are you excited for five years
later Zoom will be for sure five years
better so and so up for years but anyway
I think
from our perspective we truly believe
and in the future from a technology
perspective Zoom even can deliver uh can
deliver a much better experience than
face-to-face meeting you know you and I
can you can sit at home I can sit
anywhere let's see local Starbucks
coffee shake your hands you feel my hand
is shaking I give a hug you feel my
intimacy and even if we speak a
different language we can understand
each other and you get a cup of coffee I
can enjoy the smell remotely all those
technologies will to be part of our
offering in the future at the same time
we would like to transform our business
to be a platform Company You Know video
voice you know team chat conference and
rumor systems events webinar and also
all other collaboration Solutions
essentially in the user they can live
within the zoom platform can get most of
the work done rather than always
switching back and forth to other you
know the applications the switching
costs is very high right essentially
Zoom more like a working hybrid work
operating system that's why we are very
very excited yeah I'm excited for that
too if any of you like that Vision feel
free to join us
so you kept the world connected during a
global pandemic and brought happiness to
Millions 10 20 even 50 years from now
what do you want people to remember
about you and about Zoom
it's great questions I think one thing I
really want you know
zoom and myself to be remembered is that
you know we somewhere write a book they
would say during the you know 2020
Covenant 19 crisis there's a company
called Zoom truly have the word
truly enabled Global Connections you
know that's why that's what I want the
world to remember myself and also the
the zoom also all the Zoomies and you
know that that's pretty much but again
you know and we just you know started
our chapter two you know and we are
embarking on a zoom 2. Journey as a more
exciting stuff you know download yeah
wow wow principled and purposeful
leadership you must be a GSB Alum yep
yeah so a final question before you
before we move into audience Q and A
this is a question We'll be asking each
of our speakers as they come throughout
the year and the question is principled
leadership is Paramount at the Stanford
GSB what do you view as your role in
leading with responsibility to not only
your company but to Society at large yes
screw the question so one thing I like
Cisco and what was their The Cisco
Pharmacy chairman John Chambers he's
such a greater leader I learned one
thing from him will you look at you know
as a leader right when you look at the
business and the organization work for
don't always think about you know your
organization all with the Singapore your
organization's social responsibility
what it can do to help the the community
and Society right that's what I learned
that's why when it comes to zoom's Value
you know our company value just one word
care
to care about the community customer
company team is and as well as ourselves
to care about the community that's
extremely important make sure your
business your organization is part of a
society you think about how you can play
play differently right not only think
about a day-to-day work but also play a
big role make sure you can contribute
back to the community to the society
spoken is a true GSB alum
thank you we're now going to have a
positive test right to be a very
qualified csplr 100 thank you passed
with flying colors thank you we're now
going to move into audience Q and A I
still remember that particular day
October 27 2020 when I was in China
having a zoom interview with Harvard
Business School and right in the middle
of the interview uh you know the severe
connection issue or censorship that
might have captured my Twisted sense for
a few more whatever it was forcibly shut
me out of the meeting and never allow me
to log back in and a month later I
received a rejection letter from Harvard
Business School which supported me to
apply for the Even Better Business
School Stanford GSP where I proudly find
myself at this moment and I really
appreciate Zoom for having changed my
path in a very moving forward
laughs
[Applause]
anyway so we're gonna list of the
countless efforts made by a zoom to
improve the security and transparencies
I think there are still not a few people
who have concerns over you know zoom's
association with Chinese government and
in fact some organizations including the
Taiwanese government Japanese government
and some private company in the US still
ban the official use of two and in my
view that Zoom has been particularly
susceptible to this kind of a China
related speculations
um you know because of your personal
background and the fact that a zoom was
actually complicit in China's censorship
and repression in 2020. so my question
is how would you go about reconciling
your personal identity as a former
Chinese National holding American
passport what's the need for navigating
a multinational tech company like zoom
in such a complex and uh you know
sensitive business environment shipped
by the U.S China relationship days yeah
great question first of all I think
that's one of the best use cases right
experience about the zoom so how lucky
you are you are part of a gsv you know
so and I think it boils down to one
scene right how to build a trust right
this is very important you know all
those issues you just described boys
from advancing you know because you know
the other side you know see the
customers who never use a zoom or be
some other government they do not know
who we are right how do establish their
trust right that's right at the zoom the
speed of a trust is our favorite book
right you know the problem you mentioned
yeah I was born in China right they you
know the pandemic crisis you know came
you know a lot of users you know you
can't zoom for some Mission Control
application they do not know who I am
right and you know I'm uh you know
American citizen right they do not know
that they say oh Zoom is so maybe it's a
you know kind of a register in other
countries that's not the case right all
those issues guess what we did not do a
good job
we should proactively communicate with
the world
who
is a zoo you know what kind of uh you
know the the company and the zoom is and
also what's our company the culture and
the value animation all these kind of
things we lever that opportunity right
to communicate communicate with where
were you may not understand our business
we don't understand you know our team
may not know me right to level that
opportunity to build a trust that's why
today you look at it you know like a
president zelinski right he's using Zoom
right and also a lot of garment that you
know also you Zuma as well right but so
many security companies as well
ultimately that's a way for you to to
always take a step back to understand
what had happened I didn't understand
that problem the root of course and if
it's a greater solution you know I think
that's why you know today you know we
are doing pretty well so on that front
I just want to maybe ask you how you
share you actually your secret like to
be such a big success as a minority of
the Asian and with today we also have a
lot of international students Asian
students here do you want to like share
how to make like such a big impact as a
minority in United States and please
share some advice and experience
Hudson's great question first of all I
think again you know sitting around in
America right in a culture wise is you
know where I would say it's uh you know
open-minded right so meaning as long as
you know you work hard and contribute
right and you know I think they will
embrace you right the community and also
the the business industry and I think
that's a huge opportunity right I think
the only thing about you know you know
your background that much just think
about what you can do right to
contribute back to the community to
society right if you can you know and
show the world you know you can create a
lot of value here UB is very successful
quite a quite often the reason why in
order to successful because you know
don't think about you know from others
perspective always simple what you can
do differently every day you become
better wearing of yourself you
communicate better and also you make the
world better
and it's then actually you'll be
recognized very well your business also
will be successful ultimately I think
the the the the common mistake is is
because you do not get a better your
business will not get better and you
think about oh maybe actually you're a
minority and also you you know kind of
there are some you know discrimination I
think that's not a root cause right root
of course always focus on yourself focus
on your business and create more value
to the society that's okay
my name is jawwin Tang I am a second
year here my question is about the role
mentorship has played in your life and
your career development can you tell us
who your most influential Mentor was and
how they shaped your life
wow and we do not have a lot of time
otherwise I can share a lot of our
mentors so and I think one of the I
think you know let's you know let me
take a step back right one of the
leaders I truly think Infamous me most
in terms of leadership style is a former
CEO of Walmart it's this God right when
he talked about leadership and Cisco
offside
huge influence I image with a Blog you
know and I also had a poster you know on
on the wall in my office and I think he
is for sure is the best in terms of uh
influence to my leadership style
and also over the past several years
right you know you know quite often
right you know I see some problems and
why why I was facing challenges like I
can call a lot of sales I mean like a
you know like a salesforcee or Mark and
Oracle civil Larry and hpu seal Enrique
and also redalio and it starts a great
dealer he and his team stopped by Yama
office you know to talk with our
leadership team it will help us a lot
and also yeah quite often I can call
Manny you know CEOs right and to help me
also have our business that's what not
the reason why you know the ceiling
while you know has a great culture a lot
of leaders they want to help you out
actually you go to proactively retort
them I'm pretty sure a lot of leaders
even if they do not know you they want
to have your art right because it's hard
to give back this is part of a sitting
Valley culture
my name is Alex I'm an MBA too
um so at the beginning of the pandemic
there are obviously a lot of video
chatting uh
Services out there you know Google Plus
and Skype and of course zoom and why was
it Zoom the one that you know triumphed
in the end
great question I think the founders GSB
alumni that's a reason
because
yeah that's that's the root of calls
that's the reason so
but anyway I think
you know to build a better solution you
got to spend more time with your
customers you know ultimately what's the
Innovation Innovation really about you
want to be the first of the company
to understand customer pain point
and also take actions quickly and to be
the first winner to build a solution if
you keep doing that sooner or later you
are going to win so that's our that's
our approach that's the reason other you
know competitors I think they lost yeah
my name is uchenzo and I'm a first year
MBA student here my question is what was
the most frustrating moment in your
professional career and uh how did you
overcome the difficulties and what did
you learn from it oh that's great
question so I think
again as as too many frustration moments
in my career and you know and very often
and but however as a number one number
one thing you got to calm down that's
very very important because to be a CEO
the most important things you want to
make a better decision right if you do
not calm down and if you're very
frustrated very likely you're gonna make
a wrong decision that's very important
you got to make sure take a step back
calm down make sure you always try to
make a better decision that's that's
number one thing number two things you
know at the zoom we also and have a
formula the problem root cause solution
frustration will not help you anything
right you've got to do every time you
see the problem and the huge problem
right you probably feel frustrated
you're going to take step back just to
focus on problem root cause and a
solution another thing about if you can
have a better solution guess what you
are going to be become better company
and you every time you think wow because
there's a problem Zoom will get a better
tomorrow I'm going to become better
leader tomorrow then you should be
happier right why you feel frustrated
and that's you know my principle yeah
you talked about the importance of
patients as you were building zoom and
that it took time but now that you're a
real estate company there's also share
price pressures there's pressures of
quarterly results so how do you balance
the short-term share price
responsibility that you have versus the
long-term customer pain Point View
that's a great question I think the one
yeah this is another Mentor I my mentor
also you and learn a lot from him as
well
the company called Nvidia right and by
the founder and cogs and also the
Stanford anomaly as well see all the
student allowment accomplishment very
well so
look at you look at the media the
company history I remember there's a
Time 10 years in a row the stock price
was flat
look at it today number one semicondaga
company
because you make sure as a leader right
always focus on a long term ago right do
not focus on short term and also regard
to educated team
communicate with its team the mission of
the company is extremely important you
want to recruit retain those employees
who share the same Mission and then you
can focus on a long time ago rather than
just a short on the goal right I also I
learned a harder lesson you know over
the past several years I can tell you
our engineering team very stable I did
not lose a single top of talents but we
do we do lose a lot of sales people
because they may not understand the
company Mission right that's why I say
you know folk song and recruiting those
uh talents who can share the same
Mission focus on long term and media is
such a great example so
oh sorry I was on mute
um
[Applause]
that's the best feature for a zoo
um so Eric my name is shantam I'm a MBA
one as well my question to you is you
know Zoom really transformed within the
first three to six months I went from
talking to my grandfather's forehead to
actually hosting thousands of people on
it and you said customer was in the
center of your development but you also
had so many different types of customers
customers wanting sophistication of the
product and others wanting more basic
needs so how do you optimize for the
product development phase and the growth
phase and the communication phase of of
your product
um yeah it's a screw the question so
as time goes on right so the the
founders sealed the law you have to you
know change you know dynamically right
so for the first and several years I was
heads down to
product aside for the first four four
and a half a year five years and after
that I probably shift most of my
priority of work to go to market in a
sales and marketing but later on I
realized that's not a skillable we have
to take the turn right and sort of a
company the focused support from product
Focus to go to market folks and then
back to the product Focus you know I
needed to you know shift the model you
know to focus on the product that's what
had happened over the past six or nine
months right you have to make sure from
the top right from a civil perspective I
always look at the product side
otherwise very soon like your product
may not be best right so that's why I
dedicate a lot of other good Market you
know the responsibility the tasks to
other leaders and spend most of time on
the product side and a lot of key
features and Designs you know sometimes
in the features you think very very good
for enterprise customers may not work
for consumers and vice versa right how
to balance that make sure you know you
always simplify the product experience
and also make sure every product no
managers Engineers they truly understand
why you added this feature not you know
when you build the the product it's very
easy to add so many features but guess
what
it's not very easy to use anymore it's
so gravity right so how to balance that
you know the in the ease of use and the
feature set interest customers and also
consumers right the case make sure you
know you got into a focus part of that
you know starting from the CEO and the
founder and all the team you know and
we'll follow yeah
Eric thank you for sharing those
insights and thank you for all of your
excellent questions
but
before I click end meeting
It's A View From The Top tradition to
close with a lightning round so I'll say
a short statement and you answer with
the first thing that comes into your
head sure ready yeah always ready
most annoying Zoom habit
favorite basketball team oh Warriors for
sure so yeah got some fans uh number of
Zoom weddings you've attended
more than a dozen so
well if you're looking for any more I
have quite a few friends getting married
this year so we can we can do the
wedding ceremony host on Zoom that's the
best use case
because you even know you need to make
up Zuma has a very cool feature called
touch up your appearance right
so I'll keep that in mind uh best advice
you've ever received from your parents
hard work and stay humble
and something you can't live without
love
and I think the world that we live in
today that's something that we could all
use a bit more of Eric thank you it's
been a privilege thank you
[Music]